hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today
we're going to be talking about
creativity what it means and where it
comes from so I thought it would be well
it worked out any way that this would be
a fun time to actually be creative in
the format of the podcast this is one of
the very rare times when we're going to
have not two people on the podcast me
and somebody else not even one person as
I do in the solo podcasts but three
people on the podcast me and two other
people we've done this only once before
when we had Matthew Lutze on the program
to talk about the pleasures of wine and
Jennifer will let joined us as a guest
commentator there but now we're gonna
have two people who are experts in their
field and I will be talking to them and
that field is music and creativity in
some sense creativity is mysterious for
a lot of us we know it when we see it
but we don't know how to conjure it up
music is a nice kind of laboratory to
explore how creativity works not just
how we recognize creativity but what is
going on in our brains
so both David Rosen and Scott miles are
neuro scientists and they are also both
working musicians so they're interested
in doing neuro scientific experiments to
understand what's going on in your brain
when you're being creative they recently
published a study of jazz musicians
improvising on guitar and they show that
certain parts of the brain light up when
you are improvising and guess what the
parts of your brain that light up are
different if you are an expert jazz
musician versus if you're just a
beginner so that might give us a little
bit of insight into where creativity is
coming from creativity is not the same
for everyone and on the other side of
the coin the listener side both David
and Scott are interested in why do
people like certain kinds of music
rather than other kinds we like our
music to be a little bit patterned a
little bit predictable but not
completely predictable not just rote and
repetitive so they were actually part of
the creative team behind secret chord
laboratories that is developing
artificial intelligence software that
will help you judge whether a certain
piece of music is actually going
we enjoyed by the audience before the
audience even gets to hear it there's a
lot of different aspects to creativity
here and we're going to talk about them
in the context of music but I hope that
this actually extends beyond the simple
musical realm to creativity more broadly
that's the kind of thing that all of us
could use a little bit more of so let's
go
[Music]
all right
David Rosen and Scott miles welcome to
the mindscape podcast hi Sean thanks for
having us it's good to be here let me
let me just because I'm not used to
having two people as guests let me help
out the listeners David why don't you
say your name so we can recognize your
voice going forward
sure hi this is David Rosen all right
that's David and Scott oh this is Scott
Myles excellent and let me let me take
on the devil's advocate - what you folks
are doing here because you're thinking
about music and creativity studying it
scientifically and even thinking about
how we could album with algorithmic eyes
turn our notion of what constitutes good
music into an algorithm isn't there some
fear that you're taking all the heart
and soul out of a passionate human
endeavor oh well there certainly is a
fear but I have full confidence that
with the approach that we've been taking
you know meticulously from the very
beginning that we're doing everything we
can to make sure that those fears aren't
realized when you really look at it what
we at the heart of what we do is we look
at expectations so are the principles
that we go into and all the science of
it there's a tension release and has to
do with expectations that are developed
over time that has to do with culture
and culture or something that you know
sort of as a biological necessity of
evolution it's something that we develop
in the place where we are so it kind of
helps bond us to each other and it kind
of creates this helps like mold this
emotional bond that we have to have help
the cohesiveness of a territory right
and so one of the thing one of the
functions of music throughout time has
been to kind of give an identity to you
know to a group of people who occupy a
certain territory you know there's also
of course you know symbols or you know
you have sports teams or all these
things that identify you your accent
your customs how you greet each other
and these things are things that we
learn through exposure
and so what we've tried to do is to
model that sort of learning that that
learning is statistical and because of
the just that happens to be and I think
that this is actually not intentional
but it has benefited us through our
evolution that the place where we kind
of develop these statistical
expectations through exposure is very
proximal in the brain in the limbic
system to our emotional centers to to
the parts of our brain that process
reward and and that process this you
know like the dopamine and oxytocin and
serotonin and these feelings of
belonging togetherness and you know one
of the functions that music is served in
the past is to bond us together and
we're so passionate because of this it
has allows us to overcome you know the
fear of you know god forbid we have to
defend the territory you know you see
Braveheart and you see them painted in
their faces and that sort of thing and
then you go to a KISS concert you see
the same thing you know and so so yeah
or that you know maybe an Eagles game
right so so so that there's there's
something about this whole like adhering
to and this interplay between adhering
to these expectations which is really
what culture is all about and emotional
the emotional component to culture and
music and really what we've just tried
to do is look at that in an algorithmic
way I mean you're forming algorithms in
your brain anyhow and because of
artificial intelligence we've been able
to scale that and say okay what might
and an individual you know audience how
would how might they respond to this and
you know maybe help the industry a
little bit that way and you know let's
face it the industry is already using
algorithms and the algorithms that
they're using are not human at all we're
looking at something that's a lot closer
to the human experience which is you
know where the brain is processing the
auditory signal I think that's a
fascinating answer and actually very
different than what I expected which is
great because of course I'm not very
good at playing the devil's advocate
here I think we should be trying to
understand what goes on in the brain
while we do these things but your
emphasis on culture is really
interesting so I presume that when we
think about how music impacts the brain
there
are universal aspects that everyone you
know responds to things like rhythm and
melody but then there's also culturally
specific aspects and the talents sounds
like you spend a lot of time separating
those out or at least taking the
culturally particular aspects very
seriously yeah I think that's a really
important part of this one of the things
we say is is Neurosciences people and
expectations is culture and what I mean
by that is that the brain is really what
makes humans unique amongst all the
species in this planet our ability to
problem-solve than to think into the
future and to create plans and organize
and create hierarchies out of
information right and it's it's the
brain data really that differentiates in
terms of different analytics and
predictive algorithms the approach of
you know Scott and I being two
neuroscientists how how we want how we
think the most effective algorithms need
to have that data point to be human to
be human centered
yeah and you're right Shawn I mean there
are I mean there's this a little bit of
you know this is the classic debate in
in psychology and and a neuro psychology
cognitive science that about nurture
virtues versus nature and you know like
you like there are many scholars who say
oh the perfect fifth you know in a you
know like you know you know like the
power chord you know and music is
universal and it's every in this in
every system and and you look at and and
the in the literature you see like oh
well you know sad songs have minor
thirds and happy songs have you know
it's more consonant to have a major
third and you know people prefer duple
rhythm over triple rhythm but then you
see there's some cultures there was
actually some work done by my colleague
Jessica Jessica Phillips silver with
whom I worked at Georgetown and she
actually looked at babies who were they
just stated in you know when their
mother you would develop a lot of your
rhythmic expectations in the womb so
things that seem to be universal might
have to do actually with exposure to
just the gait of their mother
and so some of these things actually are
environmental despite how universal they
might seem and there's some work I think
it was just a Joshua McDermott at UH at
Harvard he looked and he supposedly had
found a tribe of of you know of people
in in in in South America somewhere who
did not prefer the the consonants who
didn't find like major thirds more
consonants than minor thirds but I
actually had the opportunity over Pizza
one time in Cambridge to have a debate
with him over this and what I what I
said was like you found a lack of
results but she didn't find opposite
results it'd be much more interesting
yeah I'm not not to say that it was a
great work but but I would think if I
were doing the study you know I would
say oh but it would be more interesting
if you found somebody who had the
opposite effect right and we don't find
that and so that that might mean that
like you that you're right Sean that
there are some things that are universal
and what we try to do in our algorithm
is we have there's a lot of layers that
we build into the to the you know the
machine learning and the artificial
intelligence and it has to do with
exposure and some of it is just baked
into the cake that you know these things
like major thirds or perfect fifths are
do Parilla meeven for most cultures is
something you know I mean by four four
instead of three four is something that
is is preferred but it's it's a it's a
controversy I mean even the twelve-tone
scale the chromatic scale than the major
scale minor scale within that those are
not culturally universal right other
Asian cultures and African cultures
don't always choose that am I correct
about that
mm-hmm you are yeah actually my my my
initial PhD study idea for my
dissertation was going to be to see if
grown adults you know like you know
undergrads could learn the different
tonality and the different syntactical
rules of North Indian classical music
over a few exposures and see what's
happening in their brain in fMRI and and
and and functional magnetic resonance
imaging as these rules were being
learned and there's
some foundation from for that from an
artificial you know musical system it's
called Boleyn Pierce which is kind of to
me it's kind of crazy but it's it's
weird sounding it's from the 60s
experimental I think it's like breaks
the the octave into 13 tones instead of
12 I'm like and so what we wanted to do
with that work and it kind of goes into
what our whole idea going into secret
chord is that we wanted to do something
that's more applicable and more you know
more generalizable to what people are
actually doing in their everyday life
cool so I think I think you know my I
have a million questions so I'm
hesitating and therefore I think what I
really should do is back up a little bit
I mean let's this is exciting stuff so
let's lay some of the ground work for
how we're thinking about these and then
let me just go back to the most basic
question I mean how do you to define
music what is music what is it why do we
all throughout every culture care about
it which I guess begs the question are
there cultures that don't have music at
all yes so that's actually one of the
sticking points in in the the study
about the the consonant third that
culture didn't seem to have music in any
sort of significant way Wow
so you know that's why I was that was my
counterpoint in the pizza discussion was
like it'd be interesting if they had a
completely different kind of music but
it's just an absence of music but really
you know we find in the one of the
famous landmark studies that we we kind
of base a lot of our research on out of
Robert Satori's lab in in McGill
University of Montreal was the lead
author on that was valerie lumpur and
she starts off the paper and in her
science paper in this experiment it was
the peer experiment but to live but to
start the literature review she brings
up that there was a flute discovered
from I believe it was 10,000 years ago
in Germany made out of bone and so at
the very dawn of really what we consider
you know just any kind of human species
that we would recognize as far as
civilization there was already music huh
and and what it what is the definition
maybe we'll give this one
to David like how would you define what
music is hmm I would say music to
nonverbal form of communication that
involves a series of different can be
broken down into a series of different
features and aspects and you know music
can have any or any of these aspects it
can have you know a few of these aspects
dynamics I think is important part and
melody melodic so in terms of the
movement and pitch of notes now that
shifts I think rhythms important aspect
of that
I mean rhythm doesn't just show up in
music course we have rhythm to our
speech as well I'm out the sink think
that the texture um of the sounds
there's a critical piece and that goes
right hand in hand kind of with with the
Tambor which again we see a lot of
overlap in terms of this that's why I
think the nonverbal communication I
wouldn't say there's not a language
though because you know clearly there's
there's linguistic components in music
as well I think I think that's those are
some of the core core components of it I
know that's a clear definition or
operationalize maybe Scott can give that
and a more of an operational definition
a shot well it was interesting I don't
know must have been something tells me
it might have been a drummer but there
was a reductionist kind of definition of
music then he said everything when it
comes down to it it's just rhythm
because it didn't play something fast
enough it becomes you know if you play a
beat 440 times every second it becomes
middle a you know so or high a on a
piano so and then you know you play
overtones over that and then it becomes
a Tambor and then you know the one thing
that you left out there I think was
harmony which is interesting as an
interesting omission because when I
looked at the North North Indian
classical music they have no notion of
harmony it's it's almost exclusively
mono monotonic music so at least the the
music that I encountered I remember
hearing somewhere this claim that that
sort of more primitive what we would
call primitive music ancient music but
also music from other cultures that we
western-centric people might not grow up
with is has actually much more
sophisticated rhythmic structure than
Western classical music does and sort of
when Western classical music discovered
polyphony and harmony and so forth their
their rhythmic capabilities atrophied a
little bit and it's it's more work these
days to actually discover that heritage
well david bird as an interesting
academic source there i mean he's he's
good friends you know from the talking
heads he's good friends with with
someone who's actually advised us along
the way Daniel Levinson is also at
McGill who's you know probably the
scholar to ask these sort of questions
the foundational questions of you know
why we have music in the sort of thing
he's expound upon that book upon book
but in David Burns book how music works
he said he the first chapter or the
first couple chapters it's all about
environment he talked about CBGB's and
how that that the structure of the
architecture and the wall hangings and
everything just shaped the the sound of
the talking heads early on and it talked
about how Mozart and the Protestant
Reformation why that started you know
you had more intricate sounds when you
had droning sounds and the cathedrals
because they would resonate through the
walls and he talks about Africa and
South America and then when you're
outside what's going to travel far is
going to be rhythm you know it's going
to be the base the lower notes of the
frequency and I don't know if that
accounts for any of the phenomenon that
you're bringing up Sean but it's
something to think about yeah yeah
absolutely okay so speaking of rhythm I
mean one of the things that you've done
research on is the importance of
surprise or the role of surprise let's
say in how much we like music like if
all we had was a rhythm that repeated
itself in a very basic way over and over
again we would get bored pretty quickly
whereas if all we had was either rhythm
or or melody for that matter that was
completely random and unstructured we
would be repulsed there's some happy
medium there and I know that you've been
interested in studying the extent to
which a little bit of familiarity and a
little bit of surprise plays an
important role in how much we like a
piece of music yeah so we definitely are
looking at you know expectations being
violated
and surprise and there's these two
aspects right there's there's the
familiar there's the familiar and the
surprising and there's kind of been work
done on both on both of these topics but
what we really find interesting what we
found through our research is that when
you have this right balance of
familiarity and surprise that's when you
see the optimal level of enjoyment and
dopamine and really pleasure and well we
see this on why this is occurring the
mechanisms in the brain is really
because of our two memory systems we
have an explicit memory system that is
constantly learning it's a conscious
system these are its if we relate it to
like a language model it's it's it's
declarative it in terms our Marisa
Claridge where we can recall it it's
when we've heard a song over and over
and over again and we can we can sing
along with it right and we're familiar
with that but as you're saying if we
hear the same rhythm repeating over and
over and over again that's not going to
be pleasing and it's our it's our other
system in the human brain that responds
we've seen through a number of studies
like from Ani Patel of the implicit
system responding to surprises to chords
and certain melodies and some that are
unexpected and basically when when the
memory when both memory systems when
music is occurring and both memory
systems at the same time or being
hijacked by the musical stimulus around
us that's when we see that dopamine
response and when people are really
prefering and finding their favorite
types of music yeah so it seems so like
a lot of things when you look at a
person they look like a single person
but when you study neuroscience you
realized that these different systems at
play and you know Amos Tversky you know
famously won the Nobel Prize for for
their work Kahneman and Tversky for the
economics for looking at system one
system two and and my mentor at
Georgetown looked at this with language
with procedural memory and declarative
memory sorry well you I think you should
probably explain more with system one
system to are because I'm sure yeah so
it's kind of like what what Dave was was
talking about before so your system
system one is the more implicit the more
like
rules things that you know like if
you're just if you drive home and you
forget that you drove home because it's
something that you've done over and over
and over again and it's something that's
kind of like autumn attired in your
brain but then all of a sudden if you're
driving and then and then you you know
you realize oh I was supposed to go to
the I was supposed to go to the dentist
and pick up my kid you know on the way
home then that's kind of more a system
to kind of explicit and a lot of you
know Dave's earlier his Dave's PhD work
had to do with these two systems and
jazz improvisation just a Zagat is a
great story Scott Scott's a great story
about seeing Michael Jordan in 1992 that
I think really clearly articulates the
differences between system one and
system two yeah so I mean I think that
yeah so I'm not a big sports guy you
know and so even though I made the I led
with the Eagles reference I I'm pretty
when I think of the Eagles I'm more I'm
more likely to think of Don Henley and
Glenn Frey but but yeah so you know when
I ever I go to a sports game I'm like
which one's the bass player you know and
so but then I went to see because you
know I was dating this girl and she had
tickets to see the Bulls and the bullets
in 1992 so it's like the dream team or
or whatever it is that you know the
Chicago Bulls in the early 90s yeah and
you know I went there and I'd never been
to a professional sports game before and
I'm sitting there I'm just trying to you
know get some popcorn or whatever like
you know like hang out with my
girlfriend and her father and I look out
there and I'm like wait a minute one of
these got there's like ten guys out
there running around then like and nine
of them are you know doing what I've
seen on TV or whatever you know I've
seen in the playground and all that
stuff and then this other guy is is
performing ballet right and that was
Michael Jordan and I was like yeah there
was just a merchant property of like the
way he was moving through the through
the court that was just qualitatively
distinct to me and I had no idea
anything about basketball but you know I
knew that that must have been the guy
right so okay sorry so tell us how this
explains system 1 and system 2 sure so I
can see against that so because because
in Scotts situation he really lacked the
system 2 would be the system that's
focused on more explicit controlled and
conscious knowledge in terms of
neuroscience we think of that as the
executive control Network if we're
talking about brain systems and if I'm a
fan of sports and basketball I know all
about how many championships Michael
Jordan is one I know about the slam dunk
contests of what he's why I know where
he went to college I follow him I have
his jersey right all these different
reminders that have built up that my
knowledge set of Michael Jordan all
right and let's say I know and I'm a
huge Michael Jordan fan because of this
of all the all these stats that are true
explicit knowledge with the fact that
when Scott is watching it he's really
having a more system one dominant
experience of watching Michael Jordan
because he doesn't have all of that meta
information he's responding to his to
his movement and his his visual the
visual stimulus that he's having at that
game
probably also with some cheers around
them with some auditory stimuli as well
but that's more of an implicit bottom-up
type of processing it affects like the
dorsal stream and in terms of
neuroscientific systems we think more
along the lines of the default mode
Network the trap of the reason that
people when they see that those two
things in concert are working what it
seems to be that they're working against
each other but what you really want is
you want something that's very familiar
explicitly but very surprising
implicitly and it makes sense to me if
they think that it's like dopamine is a
learning molecule so if you know
something it's like if you're watching a
movie like I think it's safe to say use
no suspects
you know if nobody's seen it spoiler
alert you know so once you get to the
end if you're watching that movie with a
friend of yours and he hasn't or she
hasn't seen it before when you get to
the end you know explicitly that there's
a twist there but you actually enjoy it
even more because you're smarter than
your friend
and your dopamine is kind of going off
and saying you know something you know
and it tricks you into thinking that
you've actually done work and that
you're more evolutionarily adapted to
your environment and if you if there's
nothing there like you said Shawn if
it's just going on and on and on if it's
just like nobody they never find cars or
Soze and that's just the regular plot
and there's no twist there's nothing to
learn there's nothing for you to know
and conversely
if you don't know then here there's
nothing for you to be smart about you
know you're not smart about the thing
that is there so it's this that's the
reason that you want new artists but
then you want to play the grooves out
and spin them on the REC on the radio or
streaming because you want to have that
fresh sound but you want everybody to
hear it over and over and over again and
it seems like those two things are
diametrically opposed but the missing
premise is there are two different brain
systems and that's what really we're
seeking to you know that's what kind of
our laboratory work is seeking to prove
there's a joke here in Hollywood would
you go to pitch your TV show to a
network the network will always say give
us exactly what's already successful and
on the air but completely different and
maybe you're explaining that I mean
maybe this is not just hypocrisy maybe
that there is this once you once you
understand the dual process notion of
how the brain works there's a in at one
system you want to be exactly what
people know in another system you want
to try surprising well don't they don't
they ask you for a meets like you have
to say it's Alf meets terms of
endearment
you know Ethel right yeah yeah I mean I
wonder how how formal we can be about
and about extending this analysis to
things like movies or novels or
something like that because it you know
in some sense music is a nice simple
test case it's you know songs are short
there's a finite number of instruments
etc we can analyze the notes but but
maybe this is a more general theory of
how we respond to art maybe even go
forward as well yeah yeah yeah so I
think it definitely applies I think your
your inclination is correct
Shawn we talk about this all the time
about narratives and story I'm a big
like sci-fi and fantasy nerd and I was
compared to like an epic trilogy right
and it's it's like the same thing this
is the second like the second act right
you're building attention you're
building attention you end on a down
moment and then that's the tension
similar to a musical moment you have
that release of a huge epic battle in
the third book and like you know and
that's you know that's the that's that
release and that's where the pleasure
really kicks off is that that was those
points between that the pushing
all of those stressors and then
releasing it which I think ultimately is
rooted in you know in in in our
evolution in which we experience they do
that but the practical part of that
Shawn is I think you kind of put your
finger on it is that with we have seven
features that we look at in music and
it's very and music is you know lends
itself to being analyzed quantitatively
you know and because the the Spotify to
the Pandora's and the academics of the
world look at features for other reasons
you know for song similarity and
recommendations we piggyback on a lot of
that work but when you're talking about
you know just like if you reduce one
frame of a 24 per frame SEC frames per
second movie that's in 4k you're talking
about 8 million pixels you know right
times 24 frames and then you have all
the different qualities and then you
have like how do you generalize and make
fuzzy boundaries around it and it it
gets a little complex but I mean that
there's always you know work on my
horizon to be done well no one ever said
a complete scientific theory of the
success of art was gonna be easy so I'm
glad that we're starting a lot of energy
here my mentor actually started my
mentor that I finished out the PhD with
his works with Renaissance paintings and
that sort of with the visual
neuroscience system he worked with
Thomas Poggio a famous visionary in
envision at MIT and so and he's actually
worked in neuro statics with that
Norberto griffith cribbage so you know
there's but there's a relationship here
reminds me of work that was done trying
to claim that abstract expressionist
paintings like Jackson Pollock were in
part successful because they were scale
free that is to say that there were
things going on on very tiny scales and
things going around medium scales and
things were scales they were fractals
yeah it was debunked a little bit
because the methodology was not that
great but there's clearly something to
it and I wonder how that also goes into
the music thing you know surprise is one
aspect but also this complexity is
another circuit right exactly
and I would also argue that there's
civilian a and the fact that you know
it's a Jackson Pollock like if somebody
gave you the same
painting and said their kid did it then
you know well I think that the hope was
that yeah we've all had this this
reaction you know yeah I could do that
my kid could do that but the idea was
that in the paintings that had become
historically very successful in Abstract
Expressionism there was something that
was not in what your six-year-old does
he really was a quantitative difference
but I think it turns out to be hard to
measure that but do you think these
thing is something like that I mean have
you studied whether something like that
is also true in music that it's not just
the surprise aspect but multi-scale
aspect is that an important thing to
people enjoying things yeah I think
that's I think this is expectation
violation and surprise has really been
at the heart of what we do but it's a
small piece of really the the greater
phenomenon of how music moves humans on
a greater scale I know one of the other
things we've talked about from work from
Carol crumb Hansel is a called cascading
reminiscence bumps and that has to do
with with the influence and and seeing
how music kind of comes but popular
music especially comes back every 20 or
25 years or so you see the 70 you see
the you know the seventies creeping back
in the other 90s and then you see you
know the eighties to come back and and
these are cycles because of when when
we're younger really the music around us
is not self selected this is during that
critical period where our implicit
systems those unconscious responses to
kind of the statistical regularities and
characteristics of music are developed
and that's really based on the decisions
of the music our parents and our family
our family members choose right and then
so we that kind of sets this implicit
standard and also from which you know
the next generation of music comes from
then the listeners who were growing up
they're ready for kind of this certain
amount of expectation violation and and
surprised and I think that's really
interesting to think about because when
the those huge identity moments of the
teenage years those years when you're
really forming your social bonds and
relationships I think that's where we
started with talking about the power of
music and how it's so important there
it's it's interesting that in terms of
popular music you really see the 13
19 or 20 year olds they're the ones who
are consuming and who are targeted the
most popular music and it may be that
and we see this consistent trend of
those top songs having these patterns of
expectation violation and surprise
because they're kind of at a at a at a
set point of you know they've learned
kind of the rules and what's going on
around them or the universe now they're
ready to take that to the next step when
we see these kind of cyclical patterns
over decades and it's a time the
cyclical patterns to your previous point
Sean about the about the Jackson Pollock
and the different levels of complexity I
think that it's important even in our
work even if we do look at at surprise
and even we're doing it looking at the
same seven features that you take into
account that some of the features can be
looked at not just as as the kind of
dependent variables but kind of to be
looked at to say okay these the the
values that we find on you know for
these parameters you know whether it be
rhythm or whether it be you know the
year of release or whatever it is
certain Tambor's they can actually set
the stage and say okay you know it's not
a linear effect so it could say this is
the condition upon which we say okay
this is now what we're this is the
paradigm that we're looking in and
almost shifts to a different thing that
wouldn't be expected because of things
like oh well their parents were
listening to this music we've got to
incorporate that in the algorithm or
like look I mean there's there's certain
levels of complexity when you brought up
the Jackson Pollock it makes me think of
John Coltrane you know I'm a big jazz
man I I name my last name is Miles I
named my son culture and Coltrane Miles
and Leto so you know Giant Steps you
know I've seen I don't know if this is
real or academically rigorous but I kind
of hear it myself I don't know if it's
just you know wishful thinking but like
I hear sort of fractal patterns in that
in that composition of giant steps and
it's almost like he's composing the
composition around the composition you
know and it's like it turns into this
kind of fractal sort of like I don't you
know I don't know how how much rigor
your mathematical rigor this would
withstand like you said just the same
thing as Jackson Pollock but that kind
of thing is not something that linearly
LoZ from a pop song you know like you
have to go to a completely different
paradigm and say okay Coltrane fans are
listening for something completely
different
you know they are ready for something
else they're not gonna you know skip
after 30 seconds if there's not a hook
you know yeah and so you're looking for
you you you kind of have to shift your
your expectations and making the
prediction well it's really interesting
how there are these Universal aspects
but they play out differently in
different people depending on their
culture their training their interests
etc but you know speaking of that cult
the you know mindscape listeners are the
Coltrane fans of the podcast world so we
went a little bit we're ready for a
little bit more depth here and I really
wanted you to explain a little bit how
you measure the surprising nough song or
any piece of music because I know
information theory is involved I know we
have wonderful podcast with Karl
Freeston who has a theory about how the
brain works that is deeply embedded in
information theory so that would be a
great connection yeah that was a great
that was a great session
I really got a lot out of that it was it
was he's singing our tune yeah
exhausting so um yeah the calculations
basically so we started off the like you
know talking about giant steps we
started off from baby steps right yep
so we basically looked at zeroth-order
so in other words zoo or thought or
harmony is what the dissertation work
was on at when I was at Georgetown when
I started working with Dave as a
research partner so we basically looked
at at a few hundred like 600 songs all
on a major key all from Johnny be good -
smells like teen spirit 1958 to 1991 you
know a little sampling yeah so of the
Billboard charts and it was
transcriptions that were that were done
by a PhD student at McGill Ashley were
going and so basically we had all the
pieces together to kind of work from and
the theory which was developed by
Leonard Meyer in 1956 257 which is that
information theory has something to do
with meaningfulness he didn't
necessarily talk about
reference but we kind of like you know
morphed it into our measure of like
billboard charting success which has its
own confounds and everybody always has a
complain about that but the more we go
to direct you know behavioral studies
and you know with with actual
participants then you can you can that
you can stop worrying about the confound
so the billboard methodology um so but
that's what we had and so basically we
looked at the top quartile which is
mainly number one maybe some number two
songs because the the long tail of
popular music and then the bottom
quartile which is like number 50 60 or
whatever down 200 and so what we did was
we we would take using the Shannon
entropy Shannon calculation from 1958 I
believe of Claude Shannon and his way of
computing complexity or entropy or
information in in in anything that's
mathematically or anything that's really
classified in different groups and that
you have a whole corpus of it so we had
the corpus which was the 600 songs that
translated about 30,000 chords and we
took those chords and we cut them off at
1/7 you know so the seventh and a ninth
and a thirteenth is pretty much the same
you know we figure you know the ear
doesn't really discriminate that much
and you know I've learned from my you
know my just teachers you can always
turn a seventh into a knife if you want
so so depending on how jazzy you want to
be right so so that was kind of we cut
him off at a seven so basically there
was about you know five or six hundred
different types of chords all in one key
so we normalized everything to like a C
major or whatever it is whatever the one
so we're we're we're differentiating
between different keys so it was a
mainly a matter of the function of the
key and then the color of the of the of
the function of the chord and the color
of the chord and then we would take okay
so let's say it's like one major like C
major and C and so that was the most
common you would probably guess if you
don't know anything about music
popular music that was the most common
out of the thirty thousand chords right
that are in all these songs right I mean
you know not just each an unique chord
but every time there's a chord and all
the songs we put it all together and we
would say okay maybe there's like five
thousand times that there's a C major if
break all the songs in a quarter notes
and I take 5,000 divided by 60 30,000
you get that number you take it's a
fraction you take the negative log base
two of it and so you get what you get is
you get a number in bits of how
surprising that quart is so that quarts
not very surprising at all it's low
around one or two bits and so our range
was like between like one or two bits to
like six bits seven bits you know like
if there's like a you know f-sharp minor
9th or whatever seventh whatever that
would be you know seven bits right so if
it only showed up once out of 30,000
chords right so that that gave us kind
of a manageable scale to work with where
we could see you know by taking the log
and you know Claude Shannon obviously
came up with that method and so that
gave us a way of saying in bits how much
information is there from each one of
these chords now if you know anything
about music theory you might be
listening to this method and saying
that's ridiculous like if I hear a C
major chord in the middle of something
like it might be very surprising I don't
care what you know but we were basically
just looking at 0th order and that's it
so it's very dumb the the algorithm
itself is dumb like it doesn't know what
came before it what came after it what
context is in it just knows what key is
in and how often it happens and we just
basically look there and surprisingly we
you know we found something what we were
able to find was that the first finding
was that there was absolute surprise
that was higher just barely like a half
a bit higher in the top quartile songs
than the bottom quartile songs and that
was consistent across the whole song so
no matter where we looked in the song
but we weren't lining them up in
sections right so then we we kind of
came up with just just to just to
clarify because I mean it that was a
great explanation but there let me just
repeated my own words so you're saying
that the most popular songs were ones in
which you were slightly more likely to
hear a chord that was slightly less
popular than in the less popular songs
that's that's exactly correct yes okay
that's an interesting finding but now
but then then there's also within the
song you're getting into
right so in order to do that so Dave and
I came up with the idea that we were
gonna look and line up the courses and
the verses and so so it's like some
convincing because I was dealing with
someone who was used to looking at
paintings and and you know visual that
sort of thing and didn't know a lot
about you know was it an expert in the
musical field but Dave and I were pretty
pretty sure that that had to be
something to do with like pre courses
and courses you know and so like you
know anything about like Max Martin he's
like you know behind the writer behind
and producer behind the you know the
Backstreet Boys and Britney Spears all
the way up to Taylor Swift and so he he
always has these like really massively
tense you know pre choruses and then
boom drops the chorus right in the face
and then you know and and he lives in a
wonderful like amazing mansion in East
Hollywood so in West Hollen is our so um
so we visited when we were out there so
I just want to see so so yeah so I mean
yeah it works right so we were trying to
see okay is this something that just
works for him or is this something that
you can actually empirically show is a
correlation and what we do is we lined
up you know we basically just took
thankfully Ashley as partisan of his
dissertation he had the notate the the
transcribers that he used actually say
what they thought was the chorus and the
verse and I sort of think so we looked
for all the verses that came right
before a chorus and sure enough there
was higher supremacist surprise effect
that you found over the whole song was
it being accounted for almost entirely
by the parts before the the courses it's
it was like the bridges obviously but
bridges came before courses too so it
was really something that looked like it
was across the whole song but it was
because we were agnostic to where in the
song you know obviously different songs
would have different places we were just
using like each song as one and we were
just saying like a half way through the
song you know whatever it's still you
know quarter way through the song and
and it just happened to be that all
these were kind of you know distributing
themselves across all the songs across
100 saw 500 songs so we had expectations
for
certain kinds of chords in general but
also at particular points in the song we
have expectations for what's going to
happen next and just tweaking that
expectation a little bit helps us make a
hit single yeah well it could it
definitely it definitely helps to I mean
I think using using that those
expectations
helps in terms of right how much of of
let's say commercial success is being
driven by these expectations and
surprise and that's a you know question
that we asked ourselves that we ask
ourselves every day but I think it
speaks also to to the common structure
of popular music and how that's
something when you know people who are
not musicians or musicologists are
familiar with that with that the
sing-along you know the chorus and then
the more kind of the more wordy verses
with more kind of it's another thing
that we kind of like talk about is you
know how does how to rhythmic patterns
of words and music also also have
impacts or of lyrics so I think that
again speaks to kind of the explicit
system and knowledge and know-how of how
these pieces of the song work but then
also when we look before and after these
key transition points is where we see
these these these large transition
points and changes in those in those
surprise moments yeah and what was it
was fascinating to me is you know the
the chorus is the part everybody knows
it has the name of the song and it
usually it's the loudest part you know
it's the hook iasts part but at least by
the metric we were looking at and that's
a big qualification harmonic surprise at
least by that difference there was no
difference whatsoever like the the
choruses looked identical in the in the
the bottom quartile songs and the top
and the number-one songs they looked
identical so what I try to say was it's
almost like when you go on vacation you
know if Dave and I have gone on vacation
and we go to the same you know place or
whatever we go to the Blue Ridge
Mountains for a weekend and Dave worked
all week you know I'm gonna make up a
crazy like unrealistic situation if Dave
worked hard or always and I didn't do
any work I don't know that would that
ever happened but you know he would
enjoy let's say he would enjoy the
vacation more because it's more of a
it's the same vacation it's the same
course you know it's like my dad
says he says the joke I told him about
this finding he says oh it's like the
guy who they asked him why are you
beating your head against the wall he
says because it feels so great when I
stop you know yeah well this is that it
was an actual physiological thing which
is you build up these opioids in your
brain that are responding to the pain
and that court that that versed can
actually it's been shown that that
actually causes this minor painful
reaction at your brain well this is what
I was wondering about because you can
say that a little bit of surprise is
good and that's probably clearly true
because like we say we don't want to
just do the same thing over and over
again but maybe not all surprises are
created equal right like I say are there
hidden variables here are there other
dimensions along which we say oh this
kind of surprise makes a song especially
compelling whereas this one would just
be annoying to us sure so that's that's
again something we think about and and
look at quantitatively you know in our
analyses and so far we've been speaking
about harmonics harmonics surprise
there's also surprise in other aspects
of the music there's in terms of the
rhythm or the melody or that or the
dynamics but I think we can really
understand how surprise and uncertainty
is related to pleasure and and
preference we think about an inverted
they inverted you Berlin's inverted you
have kind of the complexity of a
stimulus and how that's related to
pleasure and ultimately that if we think
about the x-axis as complexity we can
imagine that any single person could
have that inverted you shifted along
that axis based on their previous
experiences in their life if we go back
to kind of the fan of avant-garde free
free jazz you can imagine what their
what their set of expectations are and
how and where come we're on the
complexity axis they fall is is going to
vary based on you know by the individual
yeah so I think a key factor because
we're in that example we say okay
avant-garde jazz I'm ready to I'm ready
to lock into a 30 minute improvisation
with with very little noticeable
structure and even harm harmonies that
seem like they don't really make sense
and unclear
you know gorge chord structure but
that's like that's it is like having
that context and knowing and waiting for
this I'm gonna I'm a huge improvisation
guy that's where like my side of the
work comes on as a fan of music
improvisation and and an improviser for
20 years and different in different
bands and like for me I live for the
moment that's 15-20 minutes in where you
find this unique musical place where
maybe you even trudge through some you
know some not very moving or even good
music but then you reach this Epiphany
together and almost let go of those
evaluations and judgments and really
sink into this new place that you
reached which you wouldn't have gotten
to if not for dealing with those kinds
of those moments that may be worth
weren't as good yes so this is there's a
sweet spot and and that kind of gets to
where we are now like after we've left
you know we've come a long way since
those baby steps where now we're looking
at things like like Dave said you've not
just harmony but melody rhythm timbre
texture dynamics and so these kind of
things were able to glean through music
information retrieval automatically at
scale from thousands of songs at a time
from audio signal and so that's one of
the things that we're able to do that we
weren't we didn't really do you know we
needed a you know this kind of PhD
project from somebody else we were
building off of when we did the work
there but now as a company in sequel
court laboratories what we're able to do
is scale this and look at all those
different things and when you talk about
the sweet spot what the what we're able
to do with artificial intelligence which
is kind of where all this kind of feeds
into into the signal chain all this
information goes into our engine a doper
and you know people go a tad over comm
you know eventually when when we have
the the engine completely off and
running you know we're doing beta tests
now but like they're they'll be able to
the engine will be able to say okay in
the past in this context with those cut
these kind of predictions that you're
trying to make whether it be you know
free form improvisation of jazz or
whether it be you know Max Martin songs
from the 90s or whatever it is this is
this is the kind of waiting of the
systems or these are the sweet spots
that we that that
algorithm in the artificial intelligence
machine learning will find and apply to
get the best predictions that show that
the account for the variance in the past
and then apply those to the new songs
that you're uploading well let me ask
more about that process of creating this
improvisation or even just creating
music in general I mean I know that
you've done a little bit of research on
the neuroscience of this like the way
that the brain comes up with a piece of
music either sitting in your studio
thinking about it very hard or literally
there on the bandstand in the moment
improvising along with people what's up
with that I mean that always seems
profoundly mysterious to me are we
beginning to learn more from
neuroscience about what's actually going
on yeah so that's that really is is a
central issue of my research that's it's
been using jazz improvisation as just
what is one form of musical creativity
and and what happens in the brain when
people are generating whether whether
it's an improvised solo or they're
recording multiple takes for a vocal
tape for a course luckily I was able to
look at this intersection I was at
Drexel University so I was kind of
looking at I had two really great
advisors over there John Kuhn Yost of
the creativity Research Lab who had done
decades of work on insight and the
Eureka moments and creativity
he was my psychology advisor and then I
had an engineering a music and music
information retrieval professor Jung Moo
Kim at a music and entertainment
Technology lab and in that lab he had
been he was an MIT graduate and came
from the Media Lab and when I started
grad school he was he had a lab of
engineers and they're basically like a
feeder for places like Spotify and
Pandora and gray snow and he saw the
importance about ten years ago of not
just looking at the the engineering side
but really bringing in you know someone
with a music psychology background and
cognitive neuroscience because by
leveraging both of both of these kinds
of tools we could have a rigorous
investigation of what's happening
in the music and what's happening in the
brain as people are being creative and
so through my work as I did a series of
studies that looked at both jazz
pianists and jazz guitarists in
correlational and causational studies
that showed really distinct brain
patterns between experts and novices and
also looking at how the phenomenon of a
psychological phenomenon of flow or like
being in the zone
can also impact them creative
performance and that's been really the
topic of my work for the last met
several years so do we know the answer
sure well I can give you I can give you
kind of the the abbreviated the version
and we can dig and then we can dig in so
yeah there's two main differences that
we've found through through these
different studies first as musicians
gain expertise what we see is when
they're performing we see prefrontal
activity deactivating we call this
hypofrontality and this idea with
prefrontal activity is associated with
conscious controlled thinking jazz
improvisation happens and an
improvisation I think generally is a
really interesting topic to study
creativity and lens to study creativity
through because when we talk about
creativity I mean it's a really hard
thing to define most people most people
will agree that it has to do with
novelty and appropriateness in a given
in a given context but expertise and and
also the type of creativity is really
going to come into play so there's you
know there's the creativity of of a
small child finger-painting for the
first time and then there's the
creativity of Einstein right we're
talking about all kinds of all kinds of
different scales and so when we're
talking about you know what does it mean
to be a great creativity it really
depends on that definition
and in our studies what we did was we
looked at creativity in with two
different lenses and based on how you
categorize creativity you'll have
slightly different results so in these
studies the one component was we had
jazz musicians come into the study and
they would perform a number of jazz
solos over like a backing track
accompaniment they would be randomized
and sent out to some jazz professors and
jazz experienced jazz players a number
of them would rate them on a series of
differents different metrics one of
which was creativity another was
technical proficiency another aesthetic
appeal as you can imagine in a highly
technical domain like jazz there's lots
of overlap between those scales so we
ends up kind of yeah average we average
them into a composite quality score and
so through these studies we see is that
that when experts are performing course
of different the novices they're more
experienced they have a more robust set
of explicit knowledge and kind of if we
go back to those system one system to
approach it's it's the same the same
idea here is that through through
rigorous through rigorous training years
and years of explicit practice were able
to develop these kind of implicit
unconscious systems that are able to
perform extremely well in these highly
cognitive in this high cognitive
demanding task and that's kind of why
jazz improvisation is really interesting
creative task because in a lot of
creative tasks you have these very
distinct phases of the creative process
so if I was to this is like in terms of
talking about whether it's music or
another topic
you know composition versus
improvisation for example is there's
this ideation phase okay you know
generating lots of different ideas this
is related to one aspect of creative
thinking which is divergent thinking is
which is kind of the most tested area of
creative thought in terms of
standardized assessments is you know how
many different uses can you think of for
you know a brick or a given object and
now that's kind of like when you're
trying to come up with a new part for a
song and that's that ideation phase
I mean composition but real
the ideation phase and then the next
piece is evaluation and ultimately
modification in many domains in terms of
that cycle of the creative process
that's more evaluative right and and
what happens is you're modifying you
make edits and you're tweaking and then
you kind of maybe go back to the
ideation phase and you go through this
process it's iterative with
improvisation you get one shot and it's
also time for any of that yeah in real
time
sometimes as you know as fast as like
240 plus beats beats per minute with
chords changing perhaps at every quarter
note or every every half note and so
it's it's amazing in which some some of
the greatest jazz musicians say things
like up like Michael Miles Davis famous
quote I'll play and I'll tell you what
it is later yeah seems like it's amazing
these these eminent performers these
kind of anecdotal response to show that
they're actually letting go there let
they're releasing that cognitive control
to be in more of a state which I think
they're familiar with the state also in
terms of being that experience in terms
of getting there and are able to enter
that state more more easily of relaxing
and and performing kind of in a
bottom-up sensory kind of way yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't venture to compare
myself to Miles Davis even though we
share shares of miles part of the name
but Dave and I had a presentation that
we worked really really really super
hard on and we kind of did this kind of
like surprising thing because we're kind
of doing this meta demonstration of the
surprised effect of the music and it and
and when we finally did the presentation
which was like is in Nashville at the
BMI building in front of a bunch of
industry executives were a music
industry executives it was about six
minutes long and so there was a musical
part of it and we get to the break the
musical break you know like after the
first verse and it's the chorus and like
the second verse starts and I had the
feeling I don't know if you know Sean
like when you when you wake up when
you're on vacation somewhere and you're
jet-lagged and you just wake up and you
don't know where you are I like that
yeah
that's how I felt but I was on stage in
the middle of the performance and I was
highly engaged in the it was you know
like I was carrying the performance and
I felt like I I was waking up I didn't
remember anything that happened before
and we were like three minutes into the
performance right and I think that you
know so I mean let help me get it
straight here so there's this saying
that if you're not an expert if you have
not practiced as much if you're just an
amateur of just learning improvisation
maybe creativity more generally but at
least improvisation is more of a system
to thing because you're thinking it
you're overthinking it or you're you
know you're trying to control it very
much and then through training it
becomes a system one thing because John
McEnroe thing sure yeah I think that's a
pretty good assessment in terms of
novices in a domain I think that we
hewing each other's stories today on the
job so John McEnroe yeah I'm showing my
age a little bit he's a tennis player
really famous in the in the eighties he
was very very charismatic to say the
least screaming obscenities often on the
tennis court which is you know which was
very interesting interesting to say the
least at that time but there was a match
I believe it was during Wimbledon and
and he was getting beaten by this
underdog opponent he was it's John
McEnroe was the top ranked player in the
world at that time and in the first set
he just he was getting beat and his this
player he couldn't return his forehand
he couldn't review just couldn't hit it
back and so after sets and tennis
players will switch sides of the court
that they're occupying and as they
switched sides
John McEnroe whispered his opponents
year what are you doing today with your
forehand there's something that's going
on that I just can't hit it back like
you've really been working on that and
then after that set after that set
happened and those words were exchanged
John McEnroe beat him in straight sets
and the idea there being that you know
in tennis and similar to music it's very
much it works on you know the
intersection of really cognition in
action if you're an expert if you after
at expert yeah it's better yeah that's
the point that Sean was getting at yeah
if you're an expert you
do it complicit ly better than you do it
explicitly but if you're not you better
stick to you know maybe trying to figure
out what you're doing right yeah exactly
and this goes beyond music presumably I
mean is this a general lesson for
creativity or mastery that you know what
we aim to do by mastering the subject is
taking some of the more system to parts
of it the parts that we need really need
to think about everything we do and
transferring them into system one and
you know that's that's our goal yeah and
that's actually well that's actually one
of the one of my colleagues said one of
my the people who was the professors who
was on my dissertation committee at
Georgetown works in his he actually was
also at with poggio at MIT but he works
in with automaticity and the idea is
things going from frontal to further
back to the parietal lobe which is kind
of the top of your head and he sees that
happen over time as people practice
simple tasks yeah I mean I think it's
probably obviously true that when we
master something we want to get you know
the muscle memory or whatever it is we
want to make it automatic but it's
interesting to me that we're now able to
actually see it literally in locations
in the brain I mean how how advanced is
that project trying to see like
literally something that we would have
done with part of our brain lighting up
as we get better at it the same task
lights up a different part of our brain
yes so so it's a it's the technology
that we have available to us now really
makes that possible we've done our
series of studies with both
electroencephalography in terms of
correlational work we've I've also had
the opportunity to use transcranial
direct current stimulation which is
actually placing two electrodes on
someone's scalp non-invasively and
sending a weak electrical current into
the brain in which you kind of flip the
neuroimaging pattern our paradigm on its
head and you know in with with EEG or
fMRI research and neuroimaging what
you're looking for is to see you know
what happens in the brain when I either
have two groups of participants like
novices or experts or I have two
different tasks such as performing a
memorized melody or an improvised melody
with with the stimulation what we look
for we say if we target
this brain area and try to modulate the
activity in an inhibitory or this
inhibitory kind of way do we see a
difference in the output of the behavior
yeah and so we were able to use multi
kind of both of these methods to look at
these kind of this hypofrontality and
movement to posterior activity I think
it's important to say the difference is
really between the experts and and
novices those two different groups are
variable was kind of the number of gigs
or how much experience you'd had in jazz
but I wouldn't just I wouldn't be so
quick to say that you know we're relying
only on system 1 when you're an act when
you're an expert in system to do when
you're a novice because my theory is I
haven't tested this yet and I would love
to do this experiment is if we look at
smaller time scales specifically when
when errors happen and errors and
mistakes I know in lots of the
creativity literature associated with
you know breakthroughs of creative
performance where where a misstep like
took you on a new trajectory increased
uncertainty and then you kind of you
went with it and then when you go with
that you're resolving it and that kind
of brings it back ultimately to this the
same kind of expectation theory that we
talked about on the perception side of
things sure yeah it's like I was talking
to somebody today uh saying that I was
doing one of your old talks days
preparing for this and I was thinking
like what like a Formula One racecar
driver right you know you're just
cruising down the road you're in the
zone and all of a sudden somebody like
checks you or you know like something
happens like oh my god wait and then you
get out of it but you could get the lead
because of that because you make that
explicit decision to do something you
know different
but I think one of the one of the things
that I was thinking of when when when
Dave brought in the whole thing about
changing behavior and and whether it's
this kind of distinction between you
know Dave and and me and like in our in
our academic career of kind of trying to
use these stimuli and use music to try
to figure out discover things about the
human brain and like I think that's the
overarching you know dominant paradigm
in music cognition and I think
we're more interested in you know now
that we're like you know running a
business but also we've as musicians
because we're curious about the music is
to say okay let's let's sit back now we
have these wonderful tools that can show
us these amazing things that are
happening in the brain but we know what
they are and now that we know what these
signatures in these mercury markers are
we know there's dopamine here we know
there's certain you know neural
signatures for you know event-related
potentials when there's error when
there's which is detected which is like
surprise or this this tension and so
what we're trying to do now in our next
research and we're actually in working
with the National Science Foundation to
try to get this done in the near future
is to say okay and the things that we're
looking at in secret core laboratories
in the business end of it to say this is
what's in it this is what we think the
surprises in the music you know in this
information theory kind of caveman kind
of way but you know what that's not
accounting for like everything right and
so what why is it and like maybe we can
get some of that gap closed through
music theory and then we have more of a
music theory you know but some of that
is we need to actually bring the 13 to
19 year olds or whoever it is you know
who's consuming this music and we
actually have to tailor these controlled
stimuli and what we're actually
measuring is in the music and what the
the stimulus that we're using you know
it sounds kind of mad scientist II but
the stimulus is these kids brains you
know like we're looking at what happens
in the brains and we're trying to say
okay what gets that reaction that we
know is there because all these we're
standing on the shoulders of giants and
you know Rob's vitória Robert Satori and
all these other you know Ani Patel and
all and us you know and other the people
have made these discoveries we know what
it looks like in the brain how can we
get that reaction you see I'm saying so
we're using the brain to learn about
music and it seems like that you know
that that helps us but it also seems
like there's not enough of that in
academia even and we're continuing to
publish these results and so because
everybody's looking at you know you know
using this kind of stale controlled
music to try to see what happens in the
brain and it's not necessarily still but
you know the because
how science works you have to only
change one thing yeah and it brings up a
related issue that I wanted to get into
because we talked about improvisation
and that the test that you did David
involved individual guitarists listening
to a pre-recorded background track but
another aspect of improvisation is that
you're in a group right you can be on
stage with a bunch of people improvising
separately and I'll confess as we're
recording this on just a few days after
doing a webcast with Wynton Marsalis
Linton was one of my first guests here
on mindscape and so he returned the
favor he had me on his webcast and he's
just very interested in you know the
science or whatever we can learn about
how people are interacting there on
stage with their creativity and
certainly making mistakes was a big part
of it recovering being surprised
sometimes you're in sync
sometimes you're exactly out of sync
like people are doing ups and things and
sometimes that's okay how how far have
we gone and studying how the different
brains of different musicians are
interacting with each other up there in
real-time
well first feel free to give Wynton and
call for me I'd love to have a neuro
imaging study that's it's interesting
you say that so coming from growing up I
was a big fan of the band Phish rock
rock improvisation the kind of that's
where it was my access point to improv
before I got into fusion and jazz and
other other styles of improvisation I
think you you really hit the nail on the
head is that the what really drew really
drives that live performance with a
group is when when the synchrony happens
you know the whole the whole building
feels it when when the four or five
members are in sync together and there's
some preliminary work that's really
where I kind of found that II that you
could even record guitarists with eg
signals and the signal wouldn't be
distorted enough others a group in in
Germany who looked at dual guitarists
and an improvisation and having them
improvise together now this is you know
as you as you add more more musicians
four five six you add more complexity
you at more things are changing so
went from one's itsu and looked at duets
not not to mention looking at the that
the perceivers right you still wanna you
would also want to see if there's any
synchrony there with the audience and
that would be really special right so as
far as I know there's two places in the
world that have the types of facilities
where they have an auditorium with
neurological and physiological metrics
for an audience and musicians onstage
McMaster University and righto yeah
Canada and and the Max Planck Institute
in Germany which actually before before
I joined before I joined seek record
laboratories I was gonna head over to
Germany as a postdoc and then when we
realized that this kind of research
because we could kind of you know lead
the ship steer the ship and what exactly
what kind of music we we we choose and
an artist and how we design our studies
that's definitely on the forefront of
our research goals is further exploring
the interactions both between band
members and also the audience as well
and what you said you've gotten so far
as to get too officious management for
that
I bet it's funny Scott and I were
attending the Northeast Music cognition
conference I believe it was back in 20
2017 I think it was the week between my
for the week between my wedding and my
honeymoon and I gave a talk there and
afterwards a big fish man up in
Massachusetts came up to me he's a
medical doctor he uses Ronald Hirschberg
who looks at the clinical aspects of
music and how it can affect in
rehabilitation of military military vets
and he had been he was a huge fish fan
and he had been like record you'd
recorded with a group of a hundred
people some background vocals and told
me this whole story from 1992 and like
an old an old church and he said
Cantonese like all I could think about
now I didn't mention fish or anything
during my talk it was focusing on jazz
as we've been talking about he said all
I could think about during your talk was
doing a study with with the four guys
and fish I was like oh my god then we
used to started talking and going it's
like I know they're managed I know
they're management so I said oh we wrote
a letter to their management we included
all of our our Seavey's and our credit
our post publications and they're like
well forward it to the band's and then
you fast forward fast forward a couple
months later there's actually an
academic conference called the fish
studies conference in Oregon and I got
to go I got to go out there
get coffee with Mike Gordon right that's
good and propose and propose this study
of getting basically all four guys
hooked up to EEG devices the drumming
data probably wouldn't be so good but
look actually looking for those those
peak moments which is really what the
work focuses on is is those peak
creative moments there's quite a bit of
research looking at improvisation just
generally as an activity versus other
forms of musical performance like
composition or playing a memorized
melody but I think that's the kind of a
consistent focus that's where flow comes
into the into play is this there's
distinct peak moments that that if you
asked everyone involved who was
performing you know when were those I
believe there would be high agreement
and then so look at that underlying
brain data and musical data is
definitely a goal of mine another
fascinating aspect of the results from
this study is that we found critical
hemispheric differences to the left and
right hemisphere in the mid 90s Alcoa
and Goldberg developed and tested a
neuro cognitive theory which showed
evidence for the left hemisphere being
more engaged for routinized and habitual
tasks the right hemisphere is recruited
in more novel and unfamiliar situations
so in our study expertise or jazz
experience was significantly predictive
of the quality of an improvisation thus
when we first analyzed the brain
activity associated with high and low
quality improvisation the high quality
ones showed us both posterior shifts in
brain activity tivity and left
hemispheric activity so if we were to
define creativity by this product
definition which is what we were doing
when we're asking experts in a domain to
rate the improvisation the left
hemisphere would be critical because the
experts are likely using well learned
routines and a jazz vocabulary and
phrases they've learned over many years
to construct a solo on the spot to new
chord changes however once we
statistically controlled for expertise
then the brain activity shifted from the
left to the right hemisphere indicating
that that neural activity in the right
hemisphere underlies the more creative
improvisations once we remove the
effects of
as experience so these results represent
more of a process definition of
creativity where novelty and flexibility
are central so generally if creativity
is defined in terms of the quality of a
product like a song or an invention or a
poem or painting then the left
hemisphere plays a key role but if
creativity is understood as a person's
ability to deal with novel and
unfamiliar situations as is the case for
novice improvisers then the right
hemisphere plays a key role the other
thing you know on the flip side of this
you're both musicians in some sense
right I don't know I'm not familiar with
your work per se but I believe this is
one of the things you do how much does
this you know academic scientific study
of what's going on in the brain etc
change how you are as musicians I mean
does it affect how you play how you
enjoy how you think about your success
so it's it's interesting um so when I
came up with this I was kind of a
disgruntled have-nots disgruntled but I
was you knows and uh I wasn't yeah
anyhow I was I was having a great time
working for a Harvard neurologist
in Boston and I was also working I was
kind of not focused on put it that way
and I was working on this huge album
project and it was my first album and I
was you know trying to do everything
like independently and perfectly and
professionally and I had the Boston
string quartet and it was rented out
like WGBH for the you know Fraser
studios for their big Steinway Model D
to you know make sure everything was
perfect perfect and purest and that sort
of thing and that's really when I came
up with the idea one of our co-founders
Brian Owens who's back here in Virginia
you know I kept sending him you know
what do you think of this bridge what do
you think of this bridge he's like I
don't know they all sound the same and
so I was like and you know I was doing
fMRI and so I was looking at from Ryan
language and auditory processing and I
was like oh I can put this all together
and that's kind of how I came up with it
the short story for me as a musician is
really like working on this like you
know 60 80 hours a week for like the
next ten years after that that was 2011
right has not only occupied my time but
also
scourge me from writing new music
because I keep saying I'm very close to
knowing everything there is to know to
writing the perfect song so I'm just
gonna wait and I'll put my ideas
together then and it's kind of giving me
excuse to kind of procrastinate from the
creative side of my my musicianship yeah
there is no such thing as the perfect
song sadly it's the same right but
there's a writing or anything like that
of course yeah but it's just like the
idea that you know oh I'm gonna have you
know I'm gonna have a lot more data to
base up you know like why would I write
something now you know when I could you
know write it with the you know with the
benefit of having this you know all
these all these all these insights from
you know all the greatest songs ever in
so that's like in my mind kind of
justifying my my procrastination well
and but I still Jam since then sure and
but but finally you know you know you
we've both mentioned we you both
mentioned several times that your the
concept of flow that you know being in
the zone feeling it to what extent can
we extend this beyond not just music but
even art all the way into our lives
right you know are we learning something
here about how to live well not just
play music well is there something to be
said for becoming such an expert at life
that it becomes second nature to us and
we're in flow and in the zone sure
that's that's the philosophy that that
I've taken I think flow
I mean flow is related to pot like
positive psychology it's a theory as
work as really where it comes from as a
mental state where really individuals
are immersed in a task and there's this
intrinsic motivation that you know
really you choose to do it because just
the experience and having that energized
focus it's an it's a joyful process and
you're totally absorbed cognitively and
I think this definitely expands to I
mean I talked to my friend who codes
video games to people who you know enjoy
hiking reading is a task that's on
high-flow and for me you know I keep my
I keep my sanity by when my like yoga
routine or
or music or music practice practicing
with with my band falls out or writing
and I lose those pieces for because work
comes into play too much and I get too
caught up in other things I notice I
noticed the effects I come higher in
anxiety and maybe a little more
depressed and like when those pieces
fall out of line and I try really hard
to think it's that's like a there's a
discipline piece also of saying like you
know you don't always see the output of
writing your song and then having it be
commercially successful with or with
with or without the formula but there's
another component of just engaging in it
in a [ __ ] and developing a craft
regularly which I think makes these low
experiences more common and easier to
enter into yeah and Dave brings up the
it seems kind of paradoxical with flow
and routine right and so you think about
people like you know EXCI Jobs or Mark
Zuckerberg or like you know like where
you do things routine you know a lot of
things that we do and the company like
it was just like that
that I'll do that then people will say
like why are you so you know
obsessive-compulsive about certain
things and to me it's like you know what
I don't want to have to worry about what
I pick out you know like Steve Jobs in
the case of like wearing the turtleneck
right I don't have to worry about fun
there's no right answer to me it's like
this type of thing that there's like
nowhere to answer so why why occupy your
mind if you're like a big you know
brilliant person why you know and then
that way if you don't have to worry
about certain things if they're all
routine if you are sticking to a routine
the things that you are focused on then
you can riff on and like that's the kind
of thing that you know when we're
talking obviously it was a little bit
tongue-in-cheek about like waiting to
have the pattern to write the song but
like yeah it's like jazz right so when
you have a lead sheet and jazz you know
that the you know that the the chord
changes you know for September song or
whatever you know the chord changes are
gonna be fire you know they're gonna be
great you know it's if you do a or if
you do it like a two five one or
whatever it is you know what the chord
changes are and if you have certain
constraints then you're able to have
more of a flow state and everything else
you do
yeah you know I got a but now I don't
like it anymore because I think that
this is a I mean that's it's you're
sacrificing something for something else
sure but I don't want to be living in a
world where in order to be the best
software designer I wear the same
clothes every day I think that's right
but you have people who have secretaries
who take care of their laundry for or
take care of their phone calls you know
I'm saying so they can just like the
Rolling Stones you know I've read this
book one time it's like why are the
Rolling Stones so great because they
just get there they get out of the bus
they go on stage and they play right
they don't tune the guitars they don't
set up the gig they don't do all these
things and that's another thing you know
and get into the whole tension about the
you know you know artists are having to
do everything now because you know you
know there's no artist development and
then in the music business anymore but
you know there's a certain thing to be
said for only doing what you're a peak
performer at you know you have to wear
this there is and I I'm very you know
I'm being legitimately on I'm not
playing the devil's advocate now I'm I'm
uncertain what to think about this
because it but this is a very
provocative fact because the flip side
of that is if you're the one who tunes
the guitars you know your guitar a
little bit better right you know I
people are always surprised when I
invite them on the podcast and they're
not familiar with it and they're like
you know they mentioned my producer or
my editor and I'm like that that's all
they there's a person who is the audio
engineer here this is this is all me and
there's definitely pluses and minuses to
that right quality is not as good but at
least I understand what I think when we
talk about Flo Vera in his very general
sense we're not really talking about how
it's operationalized in terms of the
this the psychology literature and the
the work on Flo is I mean there's very
there's very little neuro scientific
work on it and um you know it's not well
studied and I think part of that is
because of the complexity there there's
nine kind of different components and so
people look at they break those into
choose subsets of components we can talk
about there's conditions that allow flow
to happen in the external so those two
main features there are is this trick
somebody hollered at me hi this book
flow 1990 is kind of the seminal
publication there but there's been a
number of papers since then so this
balance between challenge and skill as
one of the conditions and then clear
goals and feedback that's those are the
condition that's how we set up so some
some research they they choose kind of
one of these aspects such as the balance
between challenge and skill I know I've
seen some work where you know you set up
they have had people come in and do math
problems and depending on your math
ability they would create an algorithm
that would present math problems to you
and how you if you get problems wrong or
correct they would advance you or move
you back on the level and kind of have
you hooked up to some type of electrode
encephalography and look for you know
neural correlates of this facet of flow
for when we talk about this in terms of
music I think what we're missing if
we're defining flow only in terms of
balance between challenging skill which
is this condition of flow we're missing
out on the key phenomenological aspect
of flow the subjective state that people
report and experience and on that side
we talked about those dimensions include
intense concentration and immersion the
merging of action and awareness a sense
of control this the distorted sense of
time that Scott mentioned earlier and
that and critically I think the
experience of intrinsic reward so for
studies for studies that only that would
only that would encompass flow as only a
balance between challenge and skills
such as the math task I would ask you
well how much do those people love math
right so it's I think like a lot of this
comes down to like who would come to
where you are in a given day and say
you're lucky to be doing what you're
doing for a living you know like or have
that hobby or whatever it is because I
think that's what people think of when
they think of somebody who's lucky to
have a certain job or so you know like
if they're doing something that they're
good at but it's a little bit
challenging you know like like you know
like and not everybody finds that and I
think as as an educator which I know
dave has spent in his other life he
spent a lot of time esteem education
that's where thing I think we have a
long way to go in helping you know
students and children you know and
helping them find the place where in the
world where they're going to be
beneficial to society be able to feed
themselves and also come somehow reach
this kind of zone you know the most
honorable so what I conclude from this
is that life and success and creativity
are complicated and difficult but that
it's possible to make progress and learn
about them and I love the idea of using
music as sort of a paradigm for studying
all these things in the brain so David
Rosen and Scott miles thanks so much for
being on the mindscape Thank You chef
[Music]
you
[Music]